so you have a tradition at the show
right I love this tradition yeah so we
share a dressing room at our theater and
every week we award someone something
called the shucky which is this like uh
little statue John crafted with his
children right and um we give it every
week to it's like employee of the week
and so we give it every week to someone
that has gone like above and beyond in
the building and we would like to do our
weekly award here on air if we could do
we have the
shuy so here it is oh my God it's corn
John made made this home um with hand
painted and mounted from some old thing
I had in my house and he's prepared a
speech
Kelly we are so thankful that you chose
to break away from Los Angeles the West
Coast has been a little less bright
since you've been gone but New York is
stronger with you in it the chemistry is
real all I ever wanted was for shock to
be the first Broadway show to perform on
your show in A Moment Like This
I don't know the meaning of life my God
but gratitude has got to be part of it
so we made the shucky piece by piece and
now we present it to you thank you so
now shucky in hand when Christmas comes
around and you're underneath the tree
you can tell yourself this is my
December this is mine it's
mine that was good my
December you so my life would shock
without
you
is that amazing he said my life would
shook without you and I would like to
thank Texas and who for all of us we
just raising all of us what's funny is I
really assumed I was the one getting the
shule I even moved up you like ready for
your moment got the emotional
face not your time it's my time it's my
time like Goonies
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home